hey anna how's it going hey it's great
eric how are you doing
can i just say that i'm so excited about
us doing this match
i'm excited too yeah this is our first
collaboration
it should be really fun um so i guess we
should explain to
viewers what we're what we're doing yes
so the first of us to reach 10 points
will be the winner of the match
and because eric is quite a lot stronger
than me
we are doing this as an odds match so
basically eric is going to be having um
a minor piece less at the start of the
game maybe we can switch between like a
bishop or knight i don't know maybe that
makes it more
more fun to be switching yeah i'd be
happy to like alternate odds and
then we'll it'll probably lead to me
mixing up the openings a bit more
yeah yeah i think that would be super
fun so
yeah we're gonna be doing that and eric
is also gonna be having two minutes less
at the start of the game so we're gonna
be playing five plus two
and eric is gonna or i'm gonna be having
five plus two and eric is gonna have
three plus two
that's awesome yeah okay cool um
well i'm i'll mute myself good luck
and good luck yeah sounds good
see you soon okay see you
okay wait a minute did your clock change
oh her clock did change okay okay we're
good to go
um this will be this will be interesting
levy raid the levy rate thanks levy if
you actually rated
i don't know if you did though um
i uh i'm gonna try and play
my normal openings but i don't have
i should okay strategy is to play a more
closed position
of closed kind of sicilian
like d3 castling and
like just develop solidly
i'll turn on sound alerts again i guess
thanks for all of the great content on
youtube let me move this
sorry the alert box will be maybe over
my opponent's face
um i'm nervous i i don't have much time
but
um
i i see she's excited like it's weird i
can see her expression
but let's try and stay focused
how to do this maybe king and just play
solid moves
f5 might be coming um
let's try and provoke h6 move back and
then target the
the pawn this is a very karpovian idea
and usually the strategy like when
you're down a piece you want to
be careful when trading pieces like i
don't want to oversimplify i want to
keep the tension
whoa whoa it's a giant raid that's
that's so nice
69 53 it's gotham chess what's up gotham
chess
if you're just joining uh right above me
is anna kremling we're playing
we're playing an odds match this is
actually the first game so
uh i guess you're reading at a good time
um i'm giving time ons and
in this game night odds so it's gonna be
it's gonna be tricky but i'm gonna be
tricky too
hitting upon also shout out to gotham
i think i have a gotham command yeah
people should check out gotham
uh even though he's already already
probably checked out a lot
um okay i also have to stay focused but
welcome everyone
i appreciate all the comrades and gotham
emotes
and so much hype
um okay
i i have to stay focused this is
this is um
[Music]
not the happiest of situations but we
haven't traded anything yet
so it could be a long-ish game
um at some point i want to set up tricks
but
everything in box position is like so
well defended
yeah actually um i haven't mentioned
this yet this was just
like kind of confirmed earlier today but
gotham and hikaru will be doing
commentary
on a match that i'll be playing against
greg shahadi
later in this week which i'm super hyped
for
oh this is okay i'm not super hyped for
black playing f4
thanks for all the enjoyable chess
commentary
these pawns sometimes
the way to try and win a
not so good position is to just create
chaos
and just get a situation where it's hard
for the opponent to
navigate through the chaos
but it's also a way to just kind of get
into trouble quickly
because it's going to be it's going to
be complicated
also thank you whoever that was
okay so the king side's opening up and
we're probably getting a situation where
we both want to
attack on the king side um
yeah like the g4 but here i can take and
play f5
or maybe just take some knight g3 like
knight g3 keep the pawns
and then my g3 will prevent
pawn h5 and there will be looming ideas
of f5
which opens the bishop would win connect
four
and actually with the trade of
especially getting rid of my h pawn
the h file is now half open so i might
play rook h1 king g1
combined with f5 oh she's so tricky she
wants to
she wants to just do this and win my
knight
so i'm calculating rook h1 queen here
here
here and then bishop f2 almost drops the
queen but there's queen f4 bishop e3
it doesn't work um i
could play queen e1
i could consider f5 actually f5 is
interesting
f5 is probably just bad
or bishop f2 maybe bishop f2
the problem with f5 even though it would
attack the bishop get initiative
it would give away the e5 square and i
can't allow
either the bishop or knight coming to e5
so with this move i keep the knight
defended the queen defends the pawn
and i still want to play this and this
and then probably later put the bishop
back
to create some attack
also it's me maho thanks for subbing
for 14 months
um and yeah thanks everyone joining here
thanks again to levy hope you have a
good day
c3
bishop g4 is interesting
yeah my yup clock what to do takes
maybe now at five
probably not the best move
we are playing with increments so i i
can live on the increment
um queen h4 king here oh there's this
move
beat her cheeks oh it sounds cheeky
okay i'm gonna be down two pieces but i
have a nice pawn chain
uh yeah i wanted yeah that was a really
good sequence from her
because if i took i would lose the rook
which kind of rhymes
actually the problem is i'm not even
threatening to take the bishop in this
position because there's a pin
so she has time to play h5
um my plan is to bring the king here
bring the rook here
and then do things on the the files
like there's still life i mean positions
like this you kind of have to be
optimistic even when things are really
bad
um let's start with king e3
so now i am threatening to take the
bishop because my rook's now defended
um i have this move
so the king helped attack the rook
okay maybe f f6 i don't want let's play
c3
i always have to set up the tricks here
i'm just trying to be restrictive
uh she might go for this and this
what i really should do is improve the
bishop somehow
like my king might end up being a target
i might move back
i don't know what the plan is here b3 no
b3
actually b3 could be interesting
i'm sacking a pawn to try and open the b
file coming from behind
and b3 prevents knight c4 in the event
of d4
okay moving my king off alignment of the
rook
oh i can't move there i've got my rook
was tied down
let's play this going for rook f5
there's still
some outside of hope threatening a fork
okay check threatening the pawn
she's playing very solidly
but time time is dwindling for black
the bishop wants to be here now i'm
threatening the skewer
which is some hope
she can yeah this is going to be a
really strong move if she finds it
but she oh her time okay i have hope
even though i'm down three pawns and
four pieces
that's a good move
i i have to go for a dirty flag even
though there's increments
hi eric i'm writing this hi
okay screwing the knights this is what i
need just a time scramble
okay i win this when that
i'm still down a piece in three pawns
but we're not giving up
no resigning okay blockade the pawns
tricky don't hurt me
please
i'm nervous okay let's go for this idea
ah don't fork me i gain time
win this pawn
i can check and win the pawn
king might be in trouble
ah it's so close to mate check
it's so close to mate
check draw draw
oh she doesn't want to draw check
threatening bishop b1
rook cards upon oh about my rook no
okay we both forgot about my rook
no oh she's queening wait
what is this no my my
rook is hanging but she oh okay i'm
still alive
there's so many blunders there please
play this
no
i got the hope for the miracle stalemate
right
okay what a game i had chances i think
i think wow okay there's so many um
it's so hard to play in time trouble oh
man
okay but that was a good warm-up i i
think i have chances
i'm just gonna have to keep my cool
manage my time um
i think actually the plan should be to
play a hippo
playing e4 already makes some
it just allows for a
position to open up potentially so i'm
really going to try and keep the
position closed
i'm going to try and manage my time
better thank you german tourists
danka guten guten tag or guten
also thank you yeah thanks to everyone
who may be subbed
who i didn't say thank you to already um
okay i'm playing the gotham
i think gotham had a q has a chorus on
this the b3
he has an e6 b6 chorus he uses to beat
me in our match
too so i feel slightly inspiring
and the nice thing with this opening is
the the
main focus is on the dark squares rather
than light squares
um yeah we're just gonna go for a very
hippo like setup
but only half a hippo because i sadly
can't fiance
the non-existent bishop
yeah i'm gonna play a3 so we're gonna
play more fast paced
and one of the plans is actually to just
storm on the king side
i might even play some weird like rook
a2 queen a1
to get a battery uh with the queen and
bishop
combine that with rook g1 g5 put the
knight and put other knight in
um it helps to have a game plan like
going very deep into the middle game
um yeah let's waste no time just g4
and then knight g3
i'm gonna try and use uh the clock as a
weapon this game
so black is like she's playing very
principle chess
f5 is probably a good move um
because it's aiming to open that file my
king's not castled
what i can do is take and then try and
use a g file
like something something like queen h5
or even maybe i'll just slow play
like queen e2 queenside castle put the
rook on g1
and have both rooks on the king side
but it's gonna yeah it's gonna take a
lot of work like black has a nice center
up a bishop
the thing is when i castle um
it's a bit hard for black to attack
because this is always met with this
and if b5 b4 i play a4 so i can usually
keep the position closed
yeah these pawns don't scare me
i don't think
sometimes it's good to have like a
little bit of fear
so you don't let your guard down
but i feel pretty comfy here
like nice kind of you know i have enough
like home security
doors are locked
and the the thing is like black can't
really forcibly open a file
and on the king side i already have a
half movement file
yeah let's play this move oh maybe i
should have
maybe i should have left the tension
because now my bishop is just a dead
piece
but i kind of do like the structure
the question is how to continue
rook or dg1 i keep the rook on each one
to
someday push the pawn
use it as kind of a weapon to create
some weakness
time is leveling out too hey eric
proving my existence
let's go let me move the alert box so
it's not completely over
her face
we'll have it half over both of our
faces maybe
thanks for that blunder prone i'm going
to try and be less blunder
in this game compared to the previous
game
wait did i change the title i thought i
did but maybe i forgot
oh she wants to like dirty sack didn't
uh who did this
didn't ludwig or or moist critical i
think ludwig did this yesterday against
uh
moist critical it was like sac two pawns
for peace to attack
i'm probably gonna have to allow that
[Music]
what she might do probably the more
practical option i mean this is probably
very strong but
she could also move the knight back and
then play c5
now i'm slightly more terrified
because this bishop it like it's crying
in the corner
and it's completely dominated by lax
pawns and these
other pawn could come down but i'm not
getting mated
that's what matters i think
so h4h5 maybe
this might be coming wow
wait how do i how do i do this
i have knight h5 here i can just
completely ignore
the whole queen sign and attack on the
king side
it's probably the type of game that i
want knight here also maybe supports f4
if i can break up these pawns like this
bishop could turn
from my worst piece to maybe my best
piece
and g7 obviously doesn't mean target
that's a very respectable move the move
i want to play here is f4
i'm just not sure about bishop c3
i mean maybe f5 then
randomly trapping this bishop because my
pawns are oh but there's bishop a2
that would be a hilarious position let's
do it
because if here here here the bishop
blockades its own pawn
so then she can't promote checkmate me
eventually
and maybe that will give me enough time
to like triple up and
made on g7
also thank you ben the climber subbing
in tier one
i appreciate all the nice vibes and
support from chat
need some positive energy
up on time too that's the nice thing
about playing an opening like the hippo
because you just kind of blitz out the
first whatever 15 moves and then
save time for when things actually get
complicated
this resembles kind of a king's indian
attack
i might win connect four for a second
game in a row
thank you monkey library bishop a2
immediately so she was anticipating f5
uh i appreciate everything you do for
the chess community i have improved
immensely since
following you oh nice thank you for that
i appreciate your existence
okay i got the focus
it takes takes
i could end up i could maybe sack
since bishop a2 move it's kind of funny
maybe rook g5
like i want to double up actually i want
to triple up
and the rook does the most things from
the fifth rank
h6 i play rook g6
and usually like in general when there's
a pawn chain you want to attack the base
of the pawn chain
do i just allow her to take my sad
bishop
um i could also i could con but then she
gets a pawn to c3 i don't know
yeah let's double up okay my time again
so a bishop might die
it lived a good life but okay this is
actually a massive threat i think
it's not force mates but
let's start with it
queen here hitting the knight and
threatening maiden two
and my king can run and hide
bishop g it's a funny move oh but that
doesn't help because i take
yeah it's made in two this is a nice
puzzle rush tactic oh no i got fort
but queen g7 is made no matter what okay
that was a cool game i was happier with
that game
things got complicated um i mean she
she played usually what you should do is
like sack like use a piece to like sack
and then attack but
i guess my attack ended up being um a
bit quicker
with the g file uh appreciate all the
love and support
and matthew with the 300 bits
okay let's play i think without the
knight on b1
[Music]
it's it's still possible to play a
london
i'm just not going to play knight d2 at
all so we're gonna
yeah we're playing a london this game
and actually it's nice not having the
knight because my rook can move here
immediately if she ever attacks it with
queen b6
i'll play bishop d3 first
i don't want to allow any like any
forced traits
yeah like usually if the knight were
still here the move would be queen b6
uh but now oh she wants to play bishop
d6 ooh
[Music]
i think i'm okay with that we're just
gonna have a main line without a knight
how bad can it be
oh bishop e7 okay
um i'll play queen v1
i can't do this in normal chess usually
until i would play knight
d2 so queen b1 i create the sneaky
battery
and the difference between queen b1 and
queen c2
is that if she plays c4 i have a square
to retreat
while maintaining the battery
also thanks for the bits coffin season
okay so she plays uh h6 it's logical
i think i'll play a4
there's no reason for a4 but it doesn't
really change anything
and it is an attempt to just kind of
confuse
but okay she's just playing very
classically
um and actually one of the main reasons
was to delay castling
because in this position i might play g4
just go completely insane let's see her
reaction
oh she she looks so happy and then she
went from happy to sirius
but she's still like happy serious i
think
um yeah the point of g4 is to take and
then
rook g1 and if knight moves back i win
h6
so similar theme to last game like i
just want to open the file to attack
i have the the queen bishop battery this
thing
um the potential now for g5
potential for h4 as well but h4 the
problem is takes here and then h5
so let's start with g5 looks fun
yeah and now i could take with bishop or
i think i'll take with knights
so now h7 is a target square there's a
funny line knight h5
bishop check king h8 and then bishop g8
never mind okay let's play rook g1
slowly but surely i maybe could have
considered this move
but this is one idea to check force the
king over
and then rook lift
have to do some more rook lifting
it seems like she has just a very
classical style but i think in this case
uh the the normal development for black
isn't as good because um black really
should be reacting to
some of the king side threats
um i'm feeling optimistic here
yeah do you do you even rook lift bro
i'm about to bro
or the rook might just stay on the file
i might queen lift and play it by ear
um yeah i was thinking about this move
so black is giving back a pawn just to
try and trade off
some pieces
and it stops my whole evil plan of
doing check and then rook lifting good
move
so i i have a choice to me i could take
with bishop
and then get my queen and threaten
maiden after takes takes hit the queen
if the queen moves i have bishop f6
which should be winning
f6 i would take on e6
yeah what does black do against that
there's g6 in that line but 96 and then
i win
i just got the queen here and then mate
yeah so i'm keeping initiative if you
keep making threats and the opponent is
constantly on the defensive
and like from a math standpoint i have
basically three attackers and black has
fewer defenders like really only the
pawns
um and yeah as i was saying if the queen
moves i have this move
we might see 97 oh but then i take
oh queen d5 i forgot about
[Music]
oh
queen d5 very tricky
yeah i was tunneling there
um that's a really good move
i kind of want to sack my queen and then
get almost a windmill
and then i could force a draw in that
line
actually by just like moving back and
forth
uh bishop six takes takes here here
i want to play for a win though i think
i think queen h4 is probably the way to
go
like still threatening bishop f6
and the benefit here is if pawn f6 i can
just take it because
queen supports
my time's running low
but again i have a lot of attackers my
king is
remarkably safe in the center upon
what is this called a pawn hat or
pontipi
it's doing its thing
and e4 is an idea too
i'm trying in these situations you
should always be like searching for what
the player will do next
hi how's it going g was 93.
thanks for subbing
so this is it's playable like takes
wait a minute f6 i have this move 2
and then rook f7 so we might see takes
takes
takes takes and then i think only move
queen d7
and then maybe i would takes takes rook
d1 hit the queen
and we might get some end game there's a
line queen f7
takes takes and then rook d7 and i win
the bishop
so we might see queen e7 there
but then again i take takes and then
rook d7 hitting the
knight in the bishop f5 i didn't
consider
oh yeah f5 is actually playable
but i have the same idea maybe
wait a minute i'll start with taking
black would like to play this move but
then i just take
and i want to open the rook to get to d7
to get to g7 wow that's a scary move
oh no king f1 i guess oh no it's made in
two
oh no poker face
no i got triple fork mated
i'm so broken now that was such a nice
i think position there are so many great
possibilities
i tunneled in f6 i forgot about f5
well played yeah that was
such a brutal technique too the problem
is when when the knight is threatening a
triple fork
you can only save two out of the three
things
or uh one one out of the three things
like only one piece can move at the time
um i was kind of dead
yeah my pawn tp fell apart
okay i'm feeling the pain
but we're gonna go again
this time i'll be missing the f1 bishop
wait what did i just i played without
the b1 knight
i forget i forget how we started um
i think i'll play b3 we're gonna go back
to the hippo
do i have this oh i did have this i
should have done without the g1 knight
but that's okay okay it's going to be
similar um
also thank you yeah thanks people
sharing bits to sue the pain
i may have had some yeah missed
opportunities in the ass game
like missing missing some pawn pushes
play h3
gonna follow the emerging opening theory
oh another prediction i'm due to win a
game right
that's how probability works
yeah f4 may have been a possible move in
that last game
b5 okay let's ignore it
b5 is playable
i think she's just trying to confuse me
or maybe just get a pawn in my territory
okay can't complain with opening
um i kind of like the move a4
because if she takes i take with rook
and if b4 then
things kind of close down bishop is
maintaining its
pressure along the diagonal
i feel like every game i'm going for
like this this king side attack either
using the g
file using the the bishop
oh thank you miro munich and subject
submitting
almost exactly the same time i do
appreciate it
imrozen let's go thank you for awesome
streams oh thank you for
being awesome yourself sup sup j
and maybe the people who subscribed with
prime can teach others who
are trying to figure out how to
subscribe with prime
there's a way to do it okay let's play
knight g3
um wow she spent a minute on b4
yeah d4 okay we're gonna get a
hilariously closed position pawns are in
the shape of a v
hopefully stands for victory
so in this um in this case my king can
be very safe on the queen side
because the files are all closed
as long as she doesn't crazy sacrifice
stuff
[Music]
and when it's such a closed position it
usually indicates
it's going to be a long game so i do
have to be cognizant of time i'm going
to try and get away with playing some
quick moves
um if she plays g5 i don't know how the
game will progress
oh the three is a number of love thank
you gibson
and kim nice to see you again thank you
oh king abdul toronto not tomato
okay knight of five maybe
the thing is i don't want to trade the
knight for a bishop because knights are
better
in closed positions
so maybe i'll just castle play king b1
maybe she'll do be a sack
oh she might also queenside castle
[Music]
yeah that's probably good strategy for
black
okay
well i mean this the focus is gonna be
shifting
to the king side very soon
whoa oliver sauce
thanks for oh
when you win this game i'll sub and gift
five if you win two in a row oh wow oh
i'm incentivized
okay time to focus thank you oliver
sauce for
motivating me with potential sub gift
possibilities okay i'm gonna have to use
all my
tricks and resources have to use
time um
i mean i think it makes sense to just
close down the position
this game could end up being like 100
moves
but she's gonna okay she's gonna try and
play off six
um this move
i do want to play f4 i'm just trying to
figure out how it can work
and my knight's actually badly placed
so maybe what i should do is move the
queen freeing up the e2 square for the
knights
and i'll support g5 in the vent of f6
always have to be aware of this
sacrifice too
like that could be really lethal
like any knight move backwards and i'm
i'd be under some pressure
at some point i might play knight c4
to just block the bishop
going to play knight e2
and i control the f4 square so again
with this structure
the strategy is to attack the base of
the pawn chain
uh with the ventral f4 and if i get get
rid of the e5 pawn then d4 could be weak
then maybe someday my bishop can enjoy
its life
but for now oh that's a that's actually
a scary move
for now this pawn's a bit backwards this
pawn's just a
kind of a headache it's going to be so
well supported on h3
the thing is i can just ignore it now
like it's not going to go
so much further
that f4 is a real idea i think
that's actually a really good move
okay i'm gonna try and just bluff
uh rook here there is one tactical trap
the idea is if takes i take here and the
bishops overworked
she doesn't fall for it
okay so i'll take and then probably play
queen f2
so i've lost a pawn at least the
position is opening up
which could lead to more tactics
and now this pawn's a target and i have
three possibilities to fork
some vulnerable things bishop's also
target
um
[Music]
yeah that's a good move
taking knight f3
[Music]
your king is so safe my king is safe too
[Music]
and take some calculation here
did she just sneeze i saw a sneeze in my
peripheral vision
i can take it maybe play
this position is nothing to sneeze at
this move
but rook g2
g2
[Music]
takes i might i might just take and
simplify a little bit
it's not what i really want but
yeah let's do it okay so the goal is to
target
the two weak pawns in blocks position
and pray that c2 is not attacked another
time
i really should win h3 first if possible
each two might happen or that move
so i could check and then take the pawn
i think
everything i should be defended
about to win on time
[Music]
wow that's a scary move
that's an amazing move
i do this
oh no
cutting this
no i flagged oh i wanted to take on c7
but i mean the the
the plan was to take and then check and
win the rook i guess she would have had
queen c6 in that line
uh i was a little bit too slow there
that was a cool game though
sorry people losing their channel points
ah that was rough
okay uh but life goes on
uh oh she's up three to one okay come
back time
i can't get tilted
i have to stay calm this time i'll be
missing
a knight
oh there's no or there is an option for
missing g1 knight
okay
okay um
i mean i was feeling better
around this position but queen g4 was a
strong move
bishop g3 was incredible because it
removed my
my rook defending the night and my
knight was kind of pinned to the square
so i think i did what i had to do i just
maybe played a bit too slowly
um anyway okay
life moves on so no knight this time
[Music]
i'm gonna play grab because it seems
like every game i'm trying to open the g
file and why not
like make use of the fact that my rook
can come to g1
[Music]
immediately
and i'm i'm also discouraging that f6
which he's playing a lot of games
uh okay let's develop oh no my pawn
losing a pawn
yeah she's too wise for that
okay let's um let's go full grab mode
okay so the bishop supports the pawn h4
might come
i feel like this is a kind of an
improved version of what i've been
playing
of course there's some issues like i'm a
little bit overextended but
yeah that's part of life
okay so got two nice um dual pawns
[Music]
um
i might play c4 here actually
c4 is like a nice
kind of complementary move it helps
control the d5 square
the knight will be happier behind the
pawn
and will also control the square so this
is like a grab
fuse within english
i'm combining two openings it would be
cool to play something like this in like
a normal chess game
if i still have a knight here i kind of
like the harmony
for the white pieces maybe i can go for
the
the queen side grab
i could play e3 2.
e3 is a move that i was probably going
to play anyway
and i've got a tempo on the knight
and now i kind of want to sack but
now let's play this move just going in
right away
i'm preparing b4 b5
yeah i'm being very um
outgoing with my pawns
and these pieces like they're they're
all developed but they're a little bit
clunky
it's nice having just a space advantage
in this position
so i think this only helps black because
black would do this and this
so i might as well develop the bishop
first i might go for f4
and the nice thing here is black it's
kind of hard to trade pieces um
like the knight can't really be attacked
by any of the minor pieces
and it's exerting constant pressure
and if the king ever castles i'm i'm
ready to continue pawn storming
oh except that was kind of just a false
statement because h5 is bishop g5
i do have f4 though
but f4 there could be an issue with
takes
and then knight d4 so maybe i'll play b5
first and then later f4 but then c6
[Music]
there's also bishop e4
if you don't see anything wrong with
bishop e4
it's just a more efficient square for
the bishop
and now um still pressures this diagonal
pressures h7 which could be weak points
i might want to play a queen h5 to
provoke g6 and move back and play h5
or even queen h5 g6 and then queen
h6 and then combine with the bishop and
like h5 later there's some fun
possibilities here
if she plays f5i i end peasant
um and then open the g file and maybe
later like queensland castle get the
rook to g1
so rookie 8 rookie it's a useful move
because it
allows one of the minor pieces to play a
defensive role
also aligns with my king
like i wanna so now if i go for queen h6
there's bishop f8 trapping my queen
which is a little bit cruel
so maybe i'll just play like queen f3
preparing the possibility of castling
the queen is useful also because now the
f pawn
uh is only defended by the king so there
might be some idea to take on
h7 and then move in with the queen and
then
do things with the pawns
wow
this move is like so tempting but it's
just bad
um yeah not that fa that it covers h7
maybe now it's time to castle guy i
really like my chances this game
i do have to watch my time
uh but there's possibility of rook g1
[Music]
yeah if takes takes she would want to
take here i'm
i would just that made in two
and with rook g1 i might be setting up
knight f6 because takes takes a
file opens
i'm really happy with this opening
i would love to play this when i'm not
down at night
okay um g6
wow g6 i might do it
let's do it so the idea i'm sacking a
pawn and then i'm going to stack a rook
i didn't calculate this fully but it
looks promising
the calculation is
so if this one takes i win the knight if
this pawn takes i take
takes takes and then king moves over and
then
h5 threatens mate along h file
if g5 i play h6
and not to mention my bishop and then
also be aligned with the king
um the only issue is if she just ignores
this completely
and like just takes a pawn like what do
i do
oh then i take the i could take the
knife there's so many like fun looking
moves
oh maybe i okay so takes i take the
knight and then sack the rook
i just insist on giving away a rook
because after takes rook g1
ki moves here here i may so king moves
here
it's really close to me maybe queen h7
or
a queen f7 threatening queen g6 but then
rook g8
i take on e6
and bishop she's somehow surviving there
i mean i'll blitz out a few moves i
guess
i'm not seeing the mates
okay so we're going into the line i
initially calculated
yeah this isn't so clear either or is it
okay i'm gonna first kick the knights um
because i'm gonna try and meet along
this diagonal
oh
i'm kind of nervous h6 is coming though
oh there's a cool idea okay so i'm going
to stack a queen and then promote with
double checkmate
i think there's one waiver block to stop
i'm assuming the knight moves
she might lose on time
okay so oh that's a good move
right there
ah okay let's play this
no that was a mouse slip but um
i think it's still kind of working wait
how do i do this
f4 wanna open the diagonal
and all these games come down to like
crazy time scrambles
no she's trading queens
wow how did she survive that
oh my mating attack has vanished
so you played that really well
i'm not giving up though i don't know
what just happened
and we're gonna move the king i have to
use a four on two
somehow
a4 and now i can move here
i could move
okay this is a miracle it's a true
miracle
i'm winning this i'm winning this
i know how this is happening am i
winning this
how do i win the pawn
i need to take the pawn somehow
i'm winning this check and then
wait check
check check
wait this is so weird what just happened
i was dead losing
check why am i so confused king f2 i
think
there we go and then i'll take the pawn
next
man she she made um she made like a
uh unfortunate pre-move
okay here we go wow
what was this game it was a crazy game
let's go so
she really she played so well to defend
the attack
um i i hung my bishop
and then i played d6 like hoping
hoping for a miracle and then a miracle
happened like she played this
i think expecting this move and then
when i played this i think she
she just freaked out like um because you
can't
you can't stop me from promoting when
i'm attacking the knights
with a pawn on the back rank um
oops uh i wish you played a 10 minutes
game
oh well some of these games are taking
up to 10 minutes with the increment
um yeah it's kind of the nature of the
match
okay i'll miss play missing the b1
knights
okay i think we're good i'm gonna play
g4 again we're gonna repeat the same
opening
i found i found an opening that uh
i'm excited about the grub it's not uh
not a pre-match preparation
oh the queen sack line yeah there is a
line where i would get my pawn here and
then
play this and then promote with mate
but yeah we're trying to we're going to
try and keep the match moving because
we're
both of us are still very far away from
scoring 10 points
um okay yeah same opening this time i'm
missing then
this knight oh actually maybe i should
have played b4
because i don't have this rook g1 move
um for those asking this is a this is an
odds match so i start with
a bit less time and also
down a minor piece every game
um i think it's like it kind of balances
things out like all the games have been
really close so far
it's so tempting to play g6
but it's also probably just bad
h6 is a good move
because i'm either gonna have to trade
or sack
don't entirely know what to do
knight f3
okay let's that was my first wow she
pretty much that too
she was expecting it okay
yeah she maybe understands somewhat of
my my style
uh queen d7 is coming i'll put e3 in
so i'm down the pawn and at night now
but at least i have like some clear
intentions
if she ever castles queen side i'm ready
to attack
um probably b4 here
yeah it's nice uh that people can read
your channel points every game
so i'm going to try and i'm trying to
play like
to the best of my ability i do have this
move
knight d8
i think there's there's no reason to
right away like i can play this move
later
if she castles i might switch gears and
try and attack
the prom is night here
oh but then
[Music]
some f4
or f3
i actually don't know
[Music]
um let's play h3 that file could be an
issue
i don't like this opening as much as a
previous game h6 was a good move and
i may have already gone a little bit too
crazy
but there's still something to play for
her
like with every game i think um it has
been nice
just avoiding trades and getting kind of
these
very tense positions where a lot of
pieces stay on the board
uh
but she's using her piece as well
i think i'll take and then maybe cry
if i take the other way i could play
this move actually
i didn't even consider that move
initially because it's usually like a
weird
weird concept just to give back the
center but it does save the pawn
and then then my bishop can find a nice
home
a lot of these games i'm trying to use
the double fiance
and there's a chance the center can
close down
yeah so this i mean this is a kind of
recurring theme
a lot of our games so far um
when learning chess when should you
start knowing board square names by
heart
as in look at a square and instantly
know its notation
uh it comes kind of with experience
most people pick it up if you actively
play and study
you'll usually get it after like several
months to a year
but it does take time a5 was a really
good move there
i'm i'm suffering here
i'm trying to figure out how how to
avoid things crumbling like right away
i'll play b5 this moves coming
and maybe queen
how do i create chances let's move c6
i'm setting up a trap if takes i play
this and then the queen and night are
attacked
if takes i probably have to trade queens
yeah this is like usually what i don't
want to do but um
okay at least i'm not getting mated next
few moves should be easier to play like
f4
f4 is probably the main plan just to
seems like every game like she's getting
the structure
i'm trying to undermine it with my my f
on
if my knight got gets in then there's
some additional fun there's also the
potential
for this diagonal um
but that was a good move
there's also potential for the c file
just have to hold my ground keep the
game going
okay so yeah just bishop d2
if i can attack the knight knight's only
thing defending the pawn
so i'm trying to make it so black's
position will crumble
but still feels like a far ways away
from that actually happening
so bishop d2 allows rook
b2 but then i kind of just have to deal
with it
also some prospect of playing f5 and
but if i play f5 then black can get the
d5 square
and thanks for subbing tinglover oh also
cheering bits
yeah thanks everyone oliver sauce
wallacebo
sarcasa i should stay focused
um i've uh
been struggling with time this game but
her time is being beginning to dwindle
it's not clear what black actually does
knight's a bit restricted rook b6
expected
castle get that file
recur or that move
uh-oh it's rook c2
position might be crumbling but night
before i take and
try and create some complications and
pre-move this
wow good move my thing is trapped
ah my thing i have to take so i'm gonna
be down a whole rook
but i won this pawn so black doesn't
have any
past pawns anymore
it's a small victory
focus is going to shift to the king side
this pawn still defended by the rook
yeah she's simplifying oh but i can take
and take here
let's take here setting up the trap if
take side taken fork
there's rook to am
bishop f1 always gotta be hopeful
e5 potentially
that's a good move play e5
keeping the bishop here
another good move
time scramble time
just i'm keeping all the minor pieces on
the board
this
defending threatening to drop the rook
now works high down to the bishop
okay threatening to win the pawn
praying for a draw here position became
oh that's a bad move
yeah it became a lot easier to play
should have tried to keep keep the
tension
but we'll go for maybe some steal me
trap
i'm gonna go try and win the pawn
okay what are the odds i can survive
this
and her time is still dwindling
ah my bishop oh she doesn't even take it
that wasn't even stalemate either
i tried to be tricky i tried to be
tricky
uh did this move i want to try and
force like a bishop nightmate
that's a great move
like there's still some stalemate
potential but
no this is completely missing
but okay i can't resign with the time
[Music]
situation
move the night please please please
please move the night
there's a little one hope well played
very well played
really tried there
oh man there is some
i mean she played the game like really
i feel like i've learnt a lot but forget
it all when i actually play online
rolling on the floor laughing
oh oh well i hope you made me get up and
walk again um
yeah i felt some hope but um
she kept her advantage okay i'm gonna
play without the
london bishop
if i can find it
i can't find it one
huh
okay i'll play without my um i'll play
without my other bishop
okay oh thank you rmt yeah i'm not
surrendering
uh
i really have to have to think what
opening would be effective
oh no can i just lose connection
um
okay uh streamlabs is crashing which
means
wait click yes to keep streaming
i'm going to click yes hopefully it
doesn't die or do i leave it open
what happened let's file polish even
though she's swedish
what do i do do people know i still see
the chat
i just can't like streamlabs i can't
even modify anything now
when you're ready you can oh if i
relaunch the application it will close
everything
i'm just gonna not touch anything
um
an error occurred
hide it and pretend it's not there
thanks for the thing is like
lost all of its functionality
alt f4 thanks chat
um
click yes this has happened before
and then it's like when i click anything
it breaks stuff
so i'm just gonna ignore it i still see
that i'm live so that's good
um okay i'm gonna try and focus
uh
yeah down time down material stream is
dying but
i always have to look on the bright side
of life
i'll play knight c3 i'm gonna try and be
a bit more aggressive this game
which could backfire but
um like my knights are developing
towards the center
so this move and then maybe i'll
maneuver the knight to g3
yeah so i want the bishop and both
knights attacking on the king side
i'm not sure whether i should allow the
train
but maybe it's oh maybe i could play g4
actually
g4 is such a funny move
let's play g4 i'm keeping with the theme
of this uh this match
the idea is if she takes i play this and
the rook and the bishop
target the pawn
i should also note like if she ever
takes in trades i would take with queen
and i form a battery along the long
diagonal
yeah so i'm basically pretending that
this this window doesn't exist
uh like i don't want to break anything
further than it's already been broken
uh she just plays c5 yeah
okay g5
g5 is one idea
um on passant also playable
let's play g5 and this is usually the
purpose
i feel like she's getting used to my um
my like kingside flank attacks
i have to do something completely
different
a bit later also harry 20
23 i can't see any of like the
like the activity feed and stream labs
but i can see the chat so
okay um yeah that was kind of expected
i have rook h3 here
which is probably the move to play
so i'm not casting king's eye in this
game
dakota thanks for subbing or doctor go
there
for subbing for two months
so rook here it um it breaks the pin and
it defended the knight
uh that's a small surprise
i'm just gonna have to roll with the
punches she might play this move
and then i'll undevelop just because i
don't want to trade the bishop
oh she might win the pawn
but the queen side doesn't matter it's
all about attacking on the king side
um e4 f4 might be coming and she's gonna
get like pawns but
i'll have a nice pawn storm too
yeah that was the problem with moving
backwards is it leaves the rook
undefended so now the
a pawn's actually pinned
but if she plays this i can take if this
then oh then maybe i take
the problem is after takes takes knight
takes bishop b4
i'm i really don't think she'll play
anything else other than 95.
thank you gelatinous cube
appreciate the sub
yeah what to do do i close things down
do i try and open the center
i think i'll i'll go for the storm
it makes the position a bit easier to
play too
this is just about pushing pawns
wow
it's actually a yeah i forgot about that
move
if i take
my g1 maybe
that's a good move
so i would like to take
no there's my g3 maybe
i'll try knight g3
really going all in here
it really comes down to
oh wait i have a trap i can play knight
h5
wait
okay
the h5 actually depends upon my original
idea was allow her to take and then
fork the the rook and the bishop
um but there's another trap here
if takes takes takes i can play this and
i'm attacking a pawn
and nothing else
yep just gonna attack the pawn expecting
b5
b5 it solidifies the pawns
okay she probably sees it
the queen also moves on diagonals
yeah okay so she's not getting mated
i have this move i mean let's play it
because what else
i've not taken a single pawn this game
i should be calculating king h8 takes
takes double
check king f7 rook g7 king e8
and i take and it's am i winning there
knight g7 i can take
here she's gonna play queen d4
man good move but i can take in maybe
some
or um win back some pawns
okay
it's still a fight i'm winning pawns
a3 always has to be considered i
probably have to bond cloud to
defend
i'm trying to calculate the line where
i take and check and
okay here we take
getting some end game now
it locks better but it's getting
complicated because
bonds are loose probably activate the
rook
or can now swing over
whoa stephen gray thank you steven gray
that's a great move
that's such a sad square for the knight
another good move
wanna play this move
what is this position
i'm only down the pond now
my knight's ridiculous though it's just
gonna stay chilling
okay let's move the knight
knight d5 coming
okay
um have to calculate i have to go for
this
it might end up being a draw
i didn't see what to do okay i want to
check
oh now my king can actually come this
way so check
i didn't see what to do there
no it's a draw oh i was playing for a
win
i i was trying not to repeat but i guess
i lost track
wow what a game i don't think i could
have won though was i winning
maybe i could have moved the king but i
didn't want to allow this
it was really tricky it was really
tricky
yeah it's three-fold repetition the same
position happened three times
okay um we're going to play knight list
now
yeah what happens to people's points
what was the prediction both sides lose
i think the polish the prediction should
just um get cancelled
points refunded
okay so this window is still like here
but
i'm not touching it hey i forgot i i got
starbucks
the starbucks is probably room
temperature now
i got um i got a peppermint london fog
it's actually really good
i hadn't had starbucks in a while
but i felt like today was kind of a
celebration
for this match
yeah um when was it it was december 31st
i got starbucks at like 6 a.m and the
barista
the barista um went a little bit crazy
because i ordered just a normal london
fog and the barista just
decided to make me a peppermint london
fog and it was so good
so now i've been ordering peppermint
london frogs
what does it taste like so london fog
it's um
it's basically a tea latte so it's
steamed milk with earl grey tea
and usually they put in vanilla syrup
but this one it's a mix of vanilla syrup
and peppermint syrup
um oh she has coffee or she has some
beverage too
uh oh let's play wait no i was gonna mix
things up i was gonna
let's play in english i might still play
g4
let's see
okay she's playing symmetrical
yeah so e3 may be preparing g4
what if she just copies me okay let's
play g4
i don't think this would be like a bad
opening in like a normal game
like if i had a knight here there's
still some interesting ways of
developing
and then you get that kind of space on
the king side
why not ready is that a troll comment
i would love to play the ready in this
position but
i guess i could just imagine it
okay so my pawns defend i'm not going to
play g5 like that one previous game
where then she played h6 that's kind of
the issue with overextending
i can't really play a staffer either
unless could i
if i start with e3 what piece would i
have to
[Music]
i need like all the minor pieces for
stafford though
maybe i could play a stafford without my
dark squared bishop
would that work it would be just a
terrible opening but
maybe i'll do it for the lulls
um
yeah so unlike previous times i can't
extend with b4 hello sir it is time for
the sub anniversary message
oh yeah happy anniversary a
lot cove fat g and backspin
and dr mad skills
yeah so i'm playing a bit more um a bit
more solidly here
nice some nice pawn formations
oh but she castles so i probably do want
to play b4 very soon
i'll probably play d3 to over defend the
c4 pawn
and then that way i can play b4 and not
not blunder c4
i like this bishop f5 is a very fine
move i think i'll take
and then yolo i didn't calculate this
entirely through
but it looks interesting
i'm basically i'm stacking upon uh to
try and open files
i'm not sure if i should take or play
knight d5 here
as if it takes takes the d3 is weirdly
weak
e4 is not a move i want to play
there's a cool idea
um
wait um
okay i'm gonna play knight d5 there's
too many issues with allowing the knight
to come there
nice thing is the files are now gonna
maybe both be open
depending what she does
and the dream is to that's a good move
the dream is to checkmate
so i'll take i'll take this way
looks like if we trade knights on the
a-file will be open
we don't trade knights the b file stays
open
uh queen could maybe come to b3
also i'm i'm pressuring the knight a
couple times
i don't think i'm really threatening to
take it
but um if i played queen b3 then i'd be
threatening to take it because uh
the pawn would be pinned
um so very often rather than like
relieving the tension you just want to
continue adding adding more tension
d5 wow so d5 i could take and take on e5
but then the center begins to open up
another idea is to play this right away
which i think i'll do
because now if takes i can oh wait a
minute
i don't know what's happening anymore
i'm just hoping like some tactics will
work in some regard
like here she has bishop
bishop d6
wait i have time
yeah let's take
there's going to be issues along the d
file
but okay i mean there's potential here
can work with this position
[Music]
i'm actually calculating a line and d
takes c4 bishop takes e5
and then if bishop d6 i play queen a3
allowing this and then i take and then
the king goes for a walk
and then i have this move this move
i don't think it's completely winning
it's interesting though
the other option is queen b2 but
wait no oh d5 is controlled
queen d5 doesn't work in that line wait
so here
ah that probably just doesn't work
here here takes
king has to move here i have this move
i can force a draw
question is queen a2 or queen a3
it doesn't matter okay
okay so if she takes worst case scenario
i can perpetual
oh except she has king c8s
this is actually tricky to calculate
i mean she might play a6 which i also
have to be ready for
okay we're going into this i think
she'll play okay wow she plays king c8
yeah now i don't have queen c5 oh and
she has that move wow
okay that i forgot about but i have this
move
it's getting so sharp rook c5 is a
threat when my king is maybe in danger
i have 11 seconds but i still have
casting rights
i'm also threatening to take the bishop
there's a lot of tricks let's just
figure everything out with the time
ah my rook
okay the queen's tied down to defending
against meat
and i'm probably ready to castle
place that move uh
check and then like queen
expecting queen c7 there's also bishop
c7
i'm still down a piece
but i'm the one having fun now i think
she's shown she has lots of
strong defensive capabilities
arching is a bit safer now
setting up the battery that's a good
move
threading mates
no i'm getting forked okay
96 for the fork
okay this should be winning now i think
ultra pin bishop and neither pinned
it's not quite winning yet though
wow it's still going to take work okay
now it's winning
i'd better be winning
she might try some like stale matrix as
the king and
like the king is completely stuck but um
i should be in good shape here
okay if i were her i would have taken
the pawn
and then tried to sack the bishop but um
okay i won a game that was a fun game
so i'm gonna play uh wait new game
i'm playing missing my dark sword bishop
wait
how do i do this
i have to like scroll down to find the
[Music]
a custom position
[Music]
um i'm not seeing dark squared bishop
it doesn't look like there's an option
for missing the the c1 bishop
oh yeah there's not okay so i'll just be
missing um
this bishop
oh i could give an a-rook for the
stafford oh
haha actually brook odds
i'm realizing rook odds could be easier
to play
because in the middle game rooks really
don't do much
that's actually a good idea we didn't
really talk about this beforehand
but um i might
i might just challenge richer rook ons
because i'll feel more comfortable
or rook odds but no time odds the time
odds aren't actually so
uh so bad like i don't mind um
the three plus two
a lot of games were getting into
scrambles anyway
um
okay let's play i'll play d4
i might play oh no
i can't play a stone wall
because i can't i was thinking about
playing a stone wall
um i'll play one of these
i'll play this weird thing
i'm realizing yeah this is a terrible
opening for
having a dark squared bishop and no
lightsweight bishop
um play play e3
okay so this is going to be different
from the previous games
okay let's play oh can i take and just
win a pawn
i think i can
and then this move so i'm accepting the
gambit it's like a reverse queen's
gambit
and again like usual she has a center
oh no your bishop oh no yeah my
non-existent bishop
oh no
there's bishop b2 actually is kind of
interesting
we trade we trade some more
uh this moves possible
[Music]
oh i'm gonna play rook b1 this is my
first kind of impression
oh it's down it's uh it's d mcnally
thanks for subbing
for two months appreciate that i feel
like you just subbed like a week ago
but maybe time is fine
okay so we'll take here
um yeah being very aggressive
threatening to trap fork my queen and
rook
i have bishop b2
it's actually a really well played move
i have rook b2 the problem is like she
wins b4 in that line
okay i'll play rook b2
at the very least i'm gonna castle i'm
gonna be
not getting mated my king should be safe
e5 is a constant target if she ever
plays e4 the bishop gets strong
i mean she might win like all my queen
side pawns but
um i'll have something small in return
okay yep so i castle here and now this
is no longer a fork or a queen trap
um she has a choice which pawn to take
i mean if knight takes here or bishop
takes here i win the pawn
if bishop takes here i play queen a1 get
the battery
okay
hmm i'm debating whether to just sack
the pawn
it probably makes the most sense
and there's c3 but that allows knight d3
um i'm kind of liking this move actually
because i hit the bishop
and then it takes i play queen a1 and
like the the battery combined with the
knight here
it could lead to some eventual this move
or just other knight will come in
i'm trying to keep as many tricky
opportunities as possible open
just realized i left i left the tea bag
in this drink there's like two tea bags
so it's very flavorful right now the
flavor is very strong
okay
anyway i should really stay focused it's
easy
to get distract distracted
especially with starbucks
um the nice thing here is going to say
the queen was tied down
never mind i can play queen c3
there's knight f3
always watching out for like ways she
can force trades
it's hard to like force a good trade
the knight is currently pinned to the
pawn
uh the plan here is to play knight d4
attack the bishop and then eventually
knight f5
and build more pressure against g7 and
e7
i just realized the match is actually
kind of close too
one game away from kind of tying things
up
um yeah that's a very respectable move
so i could play queen d4 here
ah but then knight c6
yeah wherever my queen goes she's gonna
attack it with things
i don't want to allow any easy trades
i play this move
oh i'm really unsure i'm going to start
with this move
i mean rook seat's probably coming
i might play queen d2
i don't know
not what i wanted
yeah she just had she had too many
pieces controlling
too many squares
but there's still hope like the the
knights have potential
playing this move aligning with the
bishop but
knight still kind of pinned to the
bishop
oh that's tricky
wow very sneaky
so she just wants a queen trade
and this move almost works
okay i'm relying on tricks now
i'm relying on tricks so i'm sagging
upon if it takes i win the
thing if bishop or pawn takes i i still
play knight f5
because there's some potential pin
there's a really funny idea if she takes
with pawn i could play f4 trying to bait
her to take on passant and now they win
her queen
it's like a weird on poissant pin
but i'm going to start with knight five
hitting the bishop
then i mean i might just go for the
quick mating attack
bishop f8 is probably expected
oh the queen's defended so the the pawn
isn't actually pinned
the bishop would have to go away
um i can take with check and then win
the queen and then ring the rook
and i'll be up a rook let's go
[Music]
i think she just missed that this maybe
comes with check
um i should have enough time here
so i'm up a rook oh she looks so sad
i feel kind of bad but also
probably more happy she's gonna play
bishop d1
that's a funny move okay so i'm
targeting f7
i probably just want to like come back
and how do i attack the pawn
got maybe just win this pawn first
okay i should tie this up not used to
being up material
oh no
okay i'm still winning but i shouldn't
have allowed that
i rook out stuck okay i'm still winning
actually it simplifies things because
the bishop is less tricky than the
knight
here we go
okay
i just want to get rid of the bishop to
to simplify okay threatening a fork now
[Music]
uh the bishop is kind of slippery
there we go
no still meeting
okay
oh there's a cool checkmate coming up
if she plays on
okay this is also going to be meaning
okay
let's go so um
it's a score it's four and a half four
and a half
wow it's gonna be it's gonna be close
match
uh i'm gonna play missing
i'm playing missing a rock
because why not can i play missing a
rook
i'm gonna play missing a rock missing
the a1 rook so then i can play a
stafford
but stafford stafford is such a weird
yeah okay
okay we're we're missing a rook now
ah she doesn't play okay we're gonna
play in england
reverse england gambit down the rook
what are the odds she probably knows
this i don't know though
i'm gonna play really quickly make it
seem like i'm tilted
ah my knights
oh she knows oh she knows
oh
i tried i i pre-moved it
like but she's you know she's sensing
trickery
oh i really tried there
maybe she'll take the pawn maybe
try and fork
oh i feel so defeated okay we're gonna
i mean yeah we're gonna move on
with life for those may be confused i
have a video
about this if uh if take service takes
and wins the queen
um but none of that is happening
oh she's so happy
okay let's castle let's complete
development
and try and set up some future tricks
going for 94 it is actually refreshing
having all the minor pieces
because if i can just attack in the
middle game then the the fact that i
don't have a rook
really won't be relevant
rooks are really only relevant in the
end game
or when they lift
oh no okay i didn't see that
good move
okay so i gave it i play the dubious
gambit
and then i plundered upon knight g5 was
idea
okay at least i opened or maybe she kind
of opened the h file
[Music]
um
ah how to do this
so for this it's easy move vision e7
if i play this there's b6 and then
maybe that's the way to go
h6 is also coming not entirely sure
maybe i'll play this move
idea bishop e7 knight g3
not my proudest idea but
i'm keeping all the minor pieces on the
board
i might end up going for the
reorganization of pieces a
four is a move here but i should really
just move back
yeah she's playing this well like she
she found the tactic she didn't fall for
my trap
she's neutralizing my king's life
pressure
but now the game continues so with h6
played i have a target to maybe
do some more sacrificing
that's a really good move
yeah there goes my bishop
i really thought playing with a rook
would offer better
or without the rook would offer some
more fun
but yeah she very quickly just killed my
phone
okay there's still and black just gets a
few more moves in i don't want to trade
queens
queenie one
idea to maybe okay not blunder a queen
but maybe activate this way or this way
a really smooth game by her so far
i'm scared of any bishop move along this
diagonal like bishop here is actually an
amazing move
okay yeah bishop here would have
threatened made into and my queen
this move i still have some hope
yeah we're going to trade some more
maybe f3
so if takes i take the 9 and the is kind
of hanging
yeah it's gonna take it's gonna take
some help to to come back here
i guess if um if bishop takes takes i'm
hitting the bishop
pawn's defended i'm also hitting the
pawn in that case
um but a move like bishop f4
i'm just trying to calculate like some
potential tricks might hear
bishop g4
from a a practical point of view it's
it's good to keep both knights on the
board because those
generate the most amount of tricks
as we've seen from the previous game
and this is always a consideration for
for black
okay at least um yeah time is leveling
out
and time might induce some more blunders
and queen h4 is a good inclusion because
now there's just more pressure
and it's hard to actually exploit the
queen
though maybe there's this idea
i have to trade here it's just a
question
how to trade
i'm tempted to like sack the rook but
i think i'm gonna play knight f5 i'm
just looking for other options
oh neither five almost gets mated
wait a minute not f5 oh
okay i might have to take then
i mean these pieces are still
undeveloped my idea is to play queen
here
keeping the light defended and then
eventually in some
attacking against the queen
interesting
so if i play this i hit the queen and
threaten mate
rook team one could destroy me
rook d8 yeah good move
this move
oh there is a trick though rook d1 we
trade in knight f5
i mean it's easy to defend but
it's something
rookie i'll play queen b3 probably
almost flagged there good move
preventing rook t2 unpinning the knight
just have to keep the game going hope
for a night fork hey it's a night fork
and there's rook t4
um maybe this move preventing rook h4
attacking the rook
have this move
this move maybe okay
defend defend
h5 i play king h4
please flag please
a good move
so close to forking
i don't know what to do here c4
knight g2
another good move take and play this
she's not flogging
there goes all my pieces
please play this please please check me
please
i'm not resigning because of the one
stalemate trap
okay i resigned okay
ah like even
even when i'm down the rook like there's
all this potential like with a single
night
um i i thought tried to fight valiantly
yeah missing i guess the combination of
playing down the rook and the opening i
played was a bit tough
um but there were still chances
okay playing knightless again
yeah we got to an end game
what to do sorry pam
did you believe in me she knew my
england gambit trap it was so sad
that's first to ten so she she's a verse
across five points
what happens if we both like have nine
point five and then reach
and it could be a tied match
yeah the thing is i might try another
game playing down a rook but play like a
more stable opening because i think in
this format
um there's not so much difference
between
rook and minor peace oh oops
i i got her pawn
okay i didn't mean to do that but maybe
this makes up for
the previous game now i'm only down two
points of material
that's funny i didn't mean to do that
uh c6 is a good move so this time
someone
was requesting ready earlier so i'm
playing already
trying to play ready whoa it's 777
hey eric the first love your content
greetings from germany
oh greetings danke
guten abend and brian how's it going
shout out to brian who recently started
streaming who i think raided me
yesterday
but i didn't see it or something there
is some issue where
it didn't show um but brian should give
himself a shout out
in the chat let's play i'll play d3
okay so she has a file that's okay
oh she's playing a london our reverse
london i'll play e3 here
okay we're going to try and restrict
this bishop as much as possible
the eventual plan is
like e4 i like bishop d2
okaru does this stuff a lot but probably
more often when black is
like fiancee
and kai gofarin thanks for subbing with
prime
yeah i appreciate all the love um
i should stay focused on on these games
i want to try and like avoid getting too
low on time
but i do need to kind of choose my spots
when i think
um knight h4 here
also knight h2
start with rookie one
and thank you electricity with the love
love love
appreciate that
i'm trying to like think what style to
play in if i should just be
like really solid try and drain her time
um i mean for this position that might
be the way to go
where like i'm not going to try and
change things too much if you play z4
i'll um i'll hold my ground
yeah because i don't mind if we trade
i'm keeping all my minor pieces
the knight will probably remaneuver
to f1 just so my king can come here to
potentially defend the pawn if queen d7
is played
and then i might end up playing d4 at
some point
but i guess if she takes i have to take
this way otherwise there's
knight b3 wow
that's a bold move this move
okay things are getting spicy
yeah what to make of this g4
i mean she's there's bishop d6 check
i move back actually there's knight g3
coming
so i'm i'm trying to bait the
who was it it was ludwig the ludwig
sacrifice on g4
i mean the solid move i would expect her
to play bishop g6 just based on her her
style in these games
and then ah but knight g3 she again has
this move
so my king should be probably back a
back a square
so i might play um king h1 if she plays
bishop g6
it seems like she's calculating here
oh bishop d6 okay so king
h1 or king g1
probably king g1 just uh
[Music]
there's cases where f2 could get
attacked if she takes with bishop first
and then knight
okay so now maybe g5 knight moves and
then i win the pawn
and it's it's weird because like she's
trying to attack on the king's side and
now i'm
all of a sudden attacking myself
or doing the tagging
um takes i mean that f4 might be coming
that's a good move because neither four
is hard to stop
just have to try and weather the storm
[Music]
f3 is so ugly about what else to do
i mean if i play knight g3 there's takes
takes
bishop g3
and it still might offer me better
chances
that's a really strong move
e5 doesn't really help it's a question
between f3 and knight g3
i'm playing that g3 f3 just seemed way
too weakening
yeah we're trading a bit i could
consider taking with king
that's a move the h4
okay game goes on under pressure here i
i couldn't play f3 there's no way to
actually
defend the pawn
now we're going to slide over
so pawns are now equal because she
started without a pawn
the fact is that the a pawn actually or
the half of an a file is probably more
beneficial for her
because this is backwards f5
f4 might be coming so i'm going to stop
uh
pawn four
it's so hard though with this bishop
it's so hard to remove the bishop i have
c3 here
i want to counter-attack along the dark
squares
play this move
yeah she's trying to set up some like
battery mates
but the squares are defended
i have a feeling this is going to be
another time scramble situation
[Music]
have to pick up the pace if we trade
then the knight comes in
i mean it's oh wait i trapped the bishop
bishop's trap let's go okay coming back
here
i didn't see that i should have seen
that as a threat
i guess the queen took away the only
square from the bishop
like sometimes this is a strategy you
just have to like keep the game going
going be patient and wait for the the
tactical opportunity
the king is remarkably safe
[Music]
f4
okay i i should take maybe takes in
queen h1
she should just leave her queen here
probably rook c2 coming
but then we'll play okay so we trade
a good move i'll play
this i mean the end game's still worse
but this is
much better than being down a piece
i think i can win the pawn
of takes i think rook c1
i guess she has rookie seven here
and then
[Music]
i'll play b5 okay there we go a good
move okay
but the knights it's pinned
that's a good move i play this
i think this is working because i take
with bishop and the knight's still
pinned and i'm threatening i'm going to
get a pawn to v6
but she's still resisting let's take the
pawn
light's almost trapped there we go
okay we'll hug the rook with my pieces
and now it's me coming
okay that was a fun game i've
i mean it was kind of painful the
opening early middle game but i did
manage to survive
and manage to get the bishop trap so a
lot of this is patience
uh we'll play without a bishop
so it's tied up it's five and a half
five now and these games are close
so again it's first to ten
i do appreciate everyone sticking around
uh tuning in
it's been a fun match so far i think
this um yeah because of kind of the the
difference
in rating these sort of odds
it it levels the playing field and it
just makes uh
the games much much closer
um i'm still not sure how to play
i'll play b3 play without the bishop um
maybe i'll i'll go for an early f4
only if she develops a bishop though
what has she been she's been doing oh
she plays that move
a four might be hard to play
um but it might be possible
yeah like f4 here probably not a good
move
but let's try it it's completely
different from what i've been doing
um that's yeah that's probably a good
response
okay i'll castle
uh for new players like usually you
should avoid moving that pawn early but
there's cases where
it can open that file um
[Music]
adds a certain layer of complexity to
the position
[Music]
imrozen let's go it also enables the
queen to
come into the kingside let's go hey i
like that username
epic eric subbing for three months
appreciate that
where's my blue thingy oh yeah there's
prediction
so the way predictions kind of work in
the user interface
is that uh when you contribute channel
points to predict you'll get a
a badge saying what you predicted
so the the pink is predicting that all
i'll lose to anna
but i i like to see a lot of blue blue
badges there in the chat
maybe some people cheering for me
okay i should take with knight it does
allow a trade but
um when this is one of black's best
minor pieces
and then actually if the bishop trades
off then
my dark square bishop will just dominate
the dark squares
so i should probably develop the knight
and then bring the knight eventually to
the king's side
yeah a lot of the games like she's just
developing
i feel like she's a good role role model
for
uh for like the next generation of just
like putting her pieces on like the the
harmonious squares
meanwhile i'm just trying to make things
messy
like moving f on
doing this this opening but um it's kind
of a clash of
styles wait no no no no no no no that
was a mouse slip
i highlighted the thing okay i'm going
to treat it as a gambit
how do i fake this
oh i there was a the curse of click
click
i had clicked the thing i meant to
unhighlight the board and i
i messed up to g3 that's really
unfortunate
so now i'm giving double piece odds
man i was liking the piss i was saying
so many good things too
yeah 92 is uh i mean even takes d4 is
probably a good move
okay
is that the first mouse slip of the
match
i think it is
yeah like drawing arrows and then
clicking off
um because if i like
draw arrows and then if i like click a
square then it'll
um yeah
it's happened before um
but okay just have to learn from my
mistakes
at least i have pawns possibilities of
using the g file
and probably king h1
f5
the thing about king h1 it's it's so
risky to put the king
on the light square black has a
lightsword bishop
but i want to use the g file
the problem is this knight always
defends oh never mind
wait wait a minute
oh it's so close to working
takes takes wow that was really well
played
i want to take stakes and d5 and then
like i
it's not fair
[Music]
can i take on g7 with the rook probably
not
unless i want to lose more material
that's a sad game
okay i'm gonna try and fight with this
move
she's fighting made in one
i defend the the mate threats
i'm still threatening this so i mean
this is probably or that move
uh but now f
f5 maybe
i'm hoping for this move and then maybe
i can complicate matters
and if the bishop retreats i fork the
knights
i have takes i i skewer shish kebab
oh she's gonna checkmate me probably
i'll let her do it because i'm dead lost
there's two different mates in one yeah
ah that was unfortunate
[Music]
what to do life goes on let's um
what
oh another dollar thank you appreciate
that
let's play
uh let's play where is the thing
night odds knight on g1 okay
okay let's do this
so i'm down i'm only down by one point
could be worse
these games are not rated which is good
the casual odds games
unmute her oh is she trying to talk to
me
i i can't um i can't look at the chat
when
no okay
i just saw the comment but um she's
muted if she wanted to talk to me she
could uh just unmute herself
um i i do encourage people to watch both
streams
if you want to hear her commentary
um and i am struggling currently with uh
my streaming software okay i'm gonna
play g4 we're gonna go back to my
this is like the pro opening when you
don't have a knight
because the rook the rook can move here
as early as i could have played rook g1
i maybe next time i'll play rook g1
okay i'll play rook g1 here for the lolz
okay prediction time no mouse slipping
this game
um let's play crazy let's let's um
because she plays solidly i'm just going
to completely try and get her out of her
comfort zone
we're playing a grub combined with a
reverse panko gambit
okay so at least i have a threat
like the goal is to make the positions
as
there's two different styles of like
playing materials
either to try and make things really
crazy which is what i'm trying to do
this game
or do like the really solid patience
approach or try and
drain their time but this will be
a more crazy approach
um and actually this this diagonal is
nice because
if knight here i play this and exert
more pressure
d4 yeah she likes this move it's not a
bad move
maybe i'll play this move
just try and get rid of this pawn
enabling queen check
uh which wouldn't win a bishop because
there's knight c6
but it might be a way to just apply more
pressure to
various diagonals not to mention this
diagonal still
out of tea i still have a little bit of
of london fog
just a little bit
[Music]
um
so if takes takes i really want to
punish this
like the bishop's not defended there's
queen a4 ideas i might start simple
just this move
hey jurgle gifting
hey gifting two subs thank you mcjuggle
or gifting a total of two subs to the
channel but gifting to uh
your list tiger appreciate that
yeah i like the outcome of the opening
last time i said it
uh or said that i blundered a piece
but the fact that i i have a file for
the rook i have pressure with the g
pawn i already have the double fiancato
these checks
there's lots of ways for that to go
wrong
and it's draining a lot of time like
close to being level on time here
i should start predicting okay so we'll
take with probably knight
or let's take with knights
taking with bishop it would make an
immediate threat but it's important to
get
all the pieces into play um
and what i'm talking here is 94 hitting
the bishop and the pawn
oh this gambit worked out well this b4
move man
i feel inspired to do these sort of
things in like real chess games
like non-odds games so if i play this
there's
oh let's play this i was about to say
there's this move
hitting f2 but then i have queen a4
winning the piece
i just realized she has bishop f2 queen
b6
maybe had that
or queen b6 immediately could have been
a bit more annoying
i didn't sense the danger there
but okay this is looking really nice
if knight d5 i could take it and then
take here
i guess knight h5 would defend the pawn
but then 94 i still get initiative open
diagonal bishop here
coming
wow
what is this okay i have to take i think
queen here coming king f1 or maybe e3
i mean she might play knight g4
but i mean the thing is now queen b6 um
i moved back and the knight still
attacks so
black's not winning a piece
i'll still be down like a pawn or two
i'm up uh yeah up a lot of time here
also thank you apollo and diana
oh she's threatening
knight h2
i might have to play king g3 here
i think king g3 is probably the way to
go
wait yeah
because i mean this move looks strong
but then i check and win the night
and if check i i just walk the king up
and take the free material
um yeah okay so check in
i should be completely fine now
the king had to be brave
okay so now i i basically just won two
pieces so i won the bishop and the
knights
and we're about to trade queens or this
pawn could also fall
[Music]
um let's not be too crazy
i should probably just move the king
back
okay let's show no mercy i'm gonna get
ready to
target the the g pawn f6 might be played
or that move
okay unleashing the bishop
[Music]
um
okay pressure from all directions
and d3 is a nice move coming expecting
rook f7
or king h8
um let's take a pawn
i don't know what i'm doing let's play
this move
i mean she does have like very good
instincts when she gets long time
um okay let's take
hitting the pawn now
there we go okay
let's go it's tied it's tied again
this could can come down to the wire man
uh i was happy with that opening though
there's like this b4 gambit
okay i'm not going to play down the rook
again i don't think
uh we'll play without the bishop
oh hey spraynard k is sending me
some oh some coffee that you roasted
um oh i
i don't think i have a coffee grinder
but i would maybe
i would be willing to order one oh she
she has a hat now um i don't
do i have a hat i don't have a hat
but that's okay uh
let's play e4
i just realized i can castle more
quickly
because i don't have a bishop i can
castle move three
that's not possible in normal chess
yeah we have we have like a coffee some
sort of coffee machine
um but someone else sent me like uh i
think
some sort of coffee not beans but like
the ground beans and
um i need to get like a filter or
something
okay let's play um i don't even know
what this is
it's like b3 sicilian combined with
grand prix attack
maybe i'll just get a coffee machine
because with tea like tea i know how to
brew like i have a system for
my coffee is still a little bit foreign
or i could i could hire a personal
barista
and then that could be interesting
yes i still do share an apartment with
uh the chess bras
but they're they're more based in canada
okay i'm liking this opening this this
is reminding me of
what i usually like to play and we're
going to win connect four
she's probably going to go for the d5
and then
it would be really nice okay let's play
h3 actually
it'd be really nice if she plays d4
because she's she's been doing this to
my my bishop but
then i would just remaneuver that's a
better move
okay now at least a bishop has some
scope
the idea is to play g4 knight g3 knight
f3 eventually
ideally avoid the queen trade
i don't have a super fancy water boiler
i have this thing
it's an electric kettle um it just boils
the water
and then uh that's usually how i make my
tea
i did make tea i actually have i still
have a little bit of tea left
uh toggy tagi also let's go
i'll have to do some more research
because maybe it's time to
invest in some better beverage
technology
i take this
i should probably just
hide the king or play knight g3
let's hide the king
and the c4 is a good move
also dan len thanks for subbing with
prime
i know people are like offering
suggestions
maybe for for different kettles and
coffee makers
um i'll have to to look back
um
it's already been a lot of chess like
it's easy to to lose focus
thank you uh bacclint subbing with prime
what toaster do i have i bought like a
it's like a 15 toaster but it's super
simple you just put put bread in and
then it turns it
into toast um
i'm super happy with it
unlike this position c3 is such a
sad move which i might end up playing
i just didn't want to allow any trades
at least okay the pawn's going to have
to do something
light's restricted too
the issue is a d3 square is a bit weak
but i can work around it the queen d3 i
have
got three
oh she wants to play bishop f4 that's a
really nifty move
i might play bishop c1
it's a hard position to understand i'm
trying to calculate
a lot of things happening after bishop
f4 knight f3
like we could trade queens i think it's
all okay though
because she can't take on e4 allowing
bishop takes f4
oh but i forgot about that no
there goes my position and she's trying
to trade queens and then win c3 and f5
oh it's falling apart
well played
got really well played
bishop a3
i have to play actively
um
it's never over until it's over
probably yeah we'll probably end up
trading i do have bishop b2 here
which might be slightly preferable
but maybe we can trade this way
my bishop could be useful at some point
[Music]
that's going to be hard to crack
okay
so i'm down two pawns and a knight
type of position i probably just have to
like hunker down
try not to make life easy for her
um actually happy to see that move
because now i play this move
and then look there is a trap
imagine rook here bishop here rook here
never mind there's almost a trap
there's no trap maybe this move no
but maybe
hmm
oh there is a trap if she takes i i win
the night
there's like small stuff like this and
just try and sell up i mean
not falling for it but okay some
pressure
she's doing a really good job of like
playing solidly and
just not taking any risks
and making luft
preventing rook c2 oh except i should
have allowed rook c2 to
try and do things
okay
org f2 there's a fork
i'm in trouble
bishop kind of tries to restrict the
knight
keeping the pawn defended
i mean she could take that's one way to
simplify
if she takes on my take on e6
let's play this move
ah i'm getting forked i mean this i have
this actually
i'm still down a lot of material
okay activity nevermind
the time okay time is getting closer
play this move first
b5 probably coming
time is very much dwindling
um
i'm allowing a trade
so the rooks tie down to the knight and
the knight slide down to the pawn
so it's actually kind of weird
i can't move there i have to move here
yeah i could move
and time is still a factor
that's a free pawn
let's not get forked oh no okay she had
a fork there
just as i said let's not get forked
let's play this move
there's some stalemate idea if she plays
this
like we've almost had the same position
[Music]
before
i'm trying to hold on
oh wow
[Music]
oh no i was well played
she's not even letting me set up stale
matrix
that's kind of sad
almost one on time there
there goes the rook i might win this
it's still probably going to be a draw
but
at least i'm not losing
um i want to win both pawns if i win
both pawns there's actually
like good winning chances
to gain some time
there we go i won the most like
troublesome pond uh
it's still a theoretical draw like rook
uh rook versus knight it's a known draw
but in the time situation
it could get really tricky i still have
to be careful not to get forked
okay now the night might get stuck three
months is 25 of a year
i'm not getting forked like now the goal
is to trap the knights somehow
[Music]
not seeing it
this is so tense oh wait she's so tricky
if i took the pawn there was a fork
okay let's attack the knights
i can oh i won on time wow man this game
this game was crazy
i don't know how that happened oh man
how he loses that people can't see
that was 135 moves i can't i can't
really switch the scene
oh but maybe i can show no i can't
um i want a crazy game
[Music]
okay we're gonna go back to missing
knight
man that one game it took like probably
20 minutes right
okay moving on
yeah i'll probably put this whole match
on youtube assuming like the stream okay
i'm gonna play rook g1
for the lulz hopefully the stream like
saves
which it should like it's being
broadcast on twitch
okay yeah rook g1 novelty
we'll play c4 here
b4 okay so i'm gonna play in the style
of this previous gambit
okay
um yeah i played bishop g2 first because
i'm trying to set up takes takes and
then queen a4
would win the bishop because here i
takes takes
and then takes
so we have we have another one of these
like binko grab whatever's
taking with knight do some things
um
it's such a weird position like i'm
trying to figure out
what the plans are maybe this move
and then the king will sit weirdly on f1
also thank you your cousin duprey for
the bits
it's been a very very tense match we
started
about three hours ago
um so i do appreciate like so many
people still sticking around
okay so i induced the bishop to come to
b4 she might play a5
but then my knight can get an outpost on
b5
and then one of the plans is to play
queen a4 threatening to take and take if
she ever takes my bishop becomes strong
if she takes here i i take and win the
bishop
so there's potential for traps here
that's actually a really just solid
developing move
i'll play i'll play this because it's
hard to actually attack the bishop here
i am discouraging f5
at some point i might play knight c2 i'd
like to keep the option for this
hmm
yeah we'll see what she does one of your
vids inspired me to learn chess three
years ago oh wow
now i'm 2000 only chess and have my own
stream oh nice to see merrick
oh well shout out to sugo i dog that's
really cool i'm curious which video
because three years ago i had much fewer
videos
on youtube but maybe a st louis chess
club video
yeah f5 i was trying to discourage this
move
um i'll probably end up taking and
that file is really
[Music]
unsettling
i could play bishop bishop there's a
move
rook f
i just want to be tricky let's play this
move
oh my knight's hanging oh no
i mean i'll pretend this is all planned
out
i mean if takes i i take on g7 it's
actually kind of interesting
and then b7 could fall
[Music]
at least she'll be thinking here
um i mean i think rook f7 is the most
likely and then
i'm not sure i take the no
i'd like to find a move that like just
keeps all the pressure but it's hard
when the knight's hanging
so rook here maybe night here
and then yeah
so workout seven night here if we trade
then i'm hitting the bishop i guess the
pawn would be defended
it's probably wow i didn't see that
that's almost checkmate
i have to retreat
i was completely blind to that move
yeah because i i can't move over
knight's still hanging
[Music]
the thing is her the bishop's hanging so
if takes takes
uh then i'm threading f for g7
though there might be takes takes in
knight f5
and that's a bit troubling but then
bishop g5
oh wow there's takes takes knight f5
bishop g5
queen takes g5 rook g5 and knight e3
forking and simplifying and then my
nighting's in the end
but then her pawn hangs but that would
be just completely losing for me
so takes the knight at five is just a
really strong move
um
[Music]
hoping she plays something else
there's actually interesting idea to
take stage 9 five and then queen c1 your
videos at saint louis three or four
years ago were very inspiring and how i
discovered chess oh nice
hey cheering cheering two sets of 420
bits
so that's 840 bits from sugo idog
yeah that was kind of my um my debut
to what is this move
i mean i can't there's no reason to
think there because this is only legal
move
i'm just a little bit shocked
because now i have this move
defending the king and defending the
bishop because the pawn is now pinned
and i'm threatening to just take on g7
so i don't think she has time to take
oh man this is getting really crazy
my bishop's pinned wow that was a good
move
defending the pawn and attacking my
bishop
i have time here to think what's
material
i'm up the exchange
for two pawns
bishop's pinned
man oh i have bishops he won
defending everything it's so passive but
it's probably the way to go oh
wait the i forgot the queen also helps
attack okay so we might end up trading
though i might just take on b7 right
away
actually no i should yeah i should
remove the queen so
when i take here the bishop's no longer
pinned
though she might play this move yeah oh
but now i play this move
attacking the bishop and the tag in the
knight
she could do like the same thing that i
tried to do myself
and then we trade and i would be just
down a pawn in that line
wow so if i take
but then she takes on that was a really
good move
queen d6 is now a threat
maybe i can weather the storm you use my
student discount for prime to use free
subs on twitch
[Music]
yeah that was a good move
i'm not sure i might be getting mated
but uh
i mean things are hanging queen d6 yeah
now this move
h5
i'm living on the edge literally of the
board
or g5
queen g1
light's still hanging queen f2 queen g3
i'm still alive miraculously risky slash
brave chess space
thank you i appreciate that i'm trying
threatening maiden one and threatening
the pin
pin and win pin and win the queen's pin
and the knights pinned
pin and win oh man
that was oh that was intense
that was so uh i know such a sharp
position
that was maybe the sharpest position
we've had just in terms of chaos
i think he uses steven gray for the 1000
risky chess bits
okay so uh we're gonna go back
to missing a bishop i guess
um missing bishop
okay so i need i need one and a half
more
i'm trying to find my groove
okay some nice pins in the end there
that's a fun opening this like binko
grab
it's actually interesting like playing
this sort of like when you when you're
forced to play down material maybe
inspires uh
the creative juices maybe
i'll play a bird i'll play a bird
because then i can i can castle move
sooner
and then my pawns will be on dark
squares to make up for the fact i don't
have a darkford bishop
or wait no i don't have highlights for a
bishop i'm i'm confusing myself
what was i thinking i guess my dark
squared bishop will go here
wait what am i doing
can i banko let's play a3 i'm gonna
prepare b4
i really liked the way the last game
kinda went
yeah we're gonna do some similar things
um so it's all
all in the style of the binko like i
give away a pawn
basically to slow down box development
and get the open files for
later trickiness and king h1 is a
the move to play because this was maybe
a threat
okay and now there's a funny idea i'm
gonna
oh there's a really cool idea if she
castles
i lift my rook and just start attacking
ferociously on the king side
yeah then there's no there's no scary
discoveries
like knight c2 i would get two pieces
for the rook
this is going to be really fun because
yeah the rook's going to swing over and
i'll have
the bishop aligned the queen will come
in maybe the g pawn will push
already really excited about this
it's the benefit to keeping all the
pawns back is to
rook lift
also thank you the dread solving with
prime
also knight c8 thanks for the bits
um let's play this move
yeah so the rook went from a1 to h3 and
two moves
getting my my lifting in
i might consider some queen a1 idea
i think i'll play this move oh she wants
to play f6
the thing is i'll play queen h5
also i didn't even realize she was
running she was threatening knight f2
okay so i um i stopped the the queen
from
supporting f2
there's a funny line a queen h5 wait
never mind
i was thinking queen h5 here and then
here
and takes and then mates but queen h5 g6
i would just made immediately
okay i'm feeling optimistic i'm trying
to
calculate f6 queen here i guess g6
again i just mate if h6i
i invade
interesting
intense position
[Music]
i think i should start with queen queen
h5 and then if h6
consider g4
or even even
knight g4
sacking knight g4 would would lead to a
double p sox sacking the bishop and then
the knight
but threatening maiden one the problem
is i don't have rook g3 as a threat
and then
the rook can move over but then i play
c3
man
i don't see how she defends though
because i threaten maiden one like most
of the black pieces are on the queen
side
i think i'm gonna do it
oh no my bishop okay
if it doesn't work i'm just gonna be
down
i'm already i was already down a piece
i'm i'm gonna be down three pieces after
takes
takes but i'll have a may threat
uh knight here doesn't work because
queen each eight mates
so the bishop's still defending h8
um but of course the threat is this so
the calculation was
rook moves and then i play c3
blocking the bishop threatening this
mate
and then if the f pawn moves i check
king here and then
check and then here and then mate
[Music]
as an added bonus i attack the knight
but this is a bigger threat
it's funny most of the black pieces are
on the
queen side like they made sense earlier
but now um
it's hard to defend the king
like all black needs to do is not get
mated but
i don't see the defense like there's
random spike moves
i don't see it i think i'm not gonna
look at chat in case i'm missing
something actually
um but thanks for subbing mcquik
appreciate that
um like this is i think the only way to
try and delay mates
yeah that was it was actually really
nice
okay so check check and
check and mate i forgot i have uh
king f5 was a square so g4 is uh the
mate
okay um that was the one thing i missed
but
it actually led to a more more beautiful
finish with the pond mates
so the rook went from here to here to
here
and then delayed grab for the win
okay so now i play without a knight
i think i'll play without my b1 knight
okay this this could be it i i just need
to win one more
or draw even at first to ten
on the streak
it's hard playing so much chess like the
breen the brain kind of gets fried i'm
gonna play rook b1
because not every day you get to play
rook b1 on move one
new opening and of course uh the plan is
to polish
i'm not even gonna take i don't think
i'm probably gonna play e3
because i want the file and the diagonal
okay
all right so i'm i'm already happy with
opening
um looks like she's gonna try and play
really solidly
for a moment there i i was trying to
figure out which piece am i down but i
i don't have the knight i have i
actually have all of the king side
pieces
um
i think i'll play f4 and then there's
potential for like the bishops to just
be
massively powerful against the king side
this bishop's currently tied down to the
pawn
okay to just stay calm
and uh okay yeah she's playing solidly
really nothing wrong with the play so
far from black
um
i want i want black to castle i think
i'll play bishop d3
first i'm not going to castle myself my
king is actually really safe in the
center
uh and the plan is to play rook g1 and
start marching the g
pawn
i think i'll start actually i don't know
i could do like the the crazy rook lifts
like that previous game
but let's
i i was hesitant to play this because
it's kind of giving away my plan
but i'm gonna do it anyway and
then i didn't see what else what other
like useful move to play
and there's possibilities where the
queen wants to come this way
okay so h5 it's a sign that black won't
end up castling
if rook here might in induced d5
let's play this
there's two ideas with this move one is
to put the queen in the corner
and then so it can access the diagonal
the other idea is to
play rook g5 because i i do rook lift
bro
and both of these moves actually target
g7
but yeah she plays e5 yeah so not even
allowing me to have
so much fun so i'll move the bishop back
avoiding the trade and now i have the e5
square to work with whoa
i think we lost oh no
[Music]
she vanished i can't even
i can't even change the layout
uh that's unfortunate
oh no
um i ca i can try and
i don't even know what to do
i'll just oh we have we have the lead
singer from the
brazilian band that almost kind of looks
like me
we'll just have darkness i guess
can i find a picture of her maybe let's
find a google image
and they're cramming yeah the camera
just like gave out
um
okay no i'll just have
i i i don't need distractions right now
let's focus
um
yeah we're still on call we just neither
of us have video anymore
okay um what to do
she wants to uh chat my rook i do have
rook c3
um
there's actually some weird ideas oh my
time
okay i'm gonna play queen a1
i don't think that the weird ideas work
unfortunately
so many things rigging too
i might end up just sacking the rook and
i'll be down the rook but i'll have the
dark word bishop
also for people that want to um i guess
see anna
you can go to her stream and hear her
commentary too
um use the anna command
okay let's give away the rook
it's really not so much worse i mean the
bigger concern is my time
but there's increments
i think c4 is probably coming
then i'll maneuver the bishop to d4
where it's hard to remove
and now i i still have pressure with
this battery
it seems like a recurring theme
expecting queen e7 probably
play h3 because i just have to move
quickly
i don't think i want to play g4 but
maybe i do
she might play queen a3 here then i take
it's actually an interesting line yeah
queen a3 i
take and
yeah there's some fun in that line
eight seconds left i mean question is
what do i do if she just
makes standard moves
also thanks for subbing remain confident
okay that's what i'm trying to do
thanks for reminding me
yeah i don't know i'm just bond clowning
pretend that i'm confident
like it's not clear what black does
either it's hard to find a
a cohesive cohesive plan like the king
doesn't want to castle either way
and the knight is pinned queen side down
to the knight
okay now i play this i was hesitant to
play g4 earlier because it would open
the h file
she might end up moving back
i might want to control the huh oh but i
can't
i didn't know what to do there
i want a fork but my bishop's in the way
ah i should have avoided the queen trade
yeah we're trading down
um like this i really want to set up the
fork
no more fork
no i'm getting forked
okay doesn't play it
ah there's some hope
don't make me it's force mate
or is it walk this way
let's force me if she finds the right
move
yeah actually
i'm trying here i was really trying
no i'm getting needed ah
oh what a finish oh
okay seven and a half nine and a half
the camera gambit yeah
i can't read her reactions now
oh she's still here okay how do i do
this
okay like i hit discord for a moment
there
but okay she's back that's cool
it's been it's been a long day i'm
trying to
i'm trying to remain sane in some way
uh i could play a mcdonald attack let's
play a mcdonald attack
yeah d5 could be
oh she's preventing my rain wilson
attack
okay
so it's basically a grand prix without
my bishop
which i can live with
the bishop gets kicked around uh
and isn't useful anyways so
i don't mind this i might go for like
the crazy
like the crazy f5 move
but probably not maybe queen h5
or queen h4
queens 4 then f5
i have to play this differently it's
it's weird
um
maybe knight c3
actually let's play um i think i'll play
c3
i'll develop the knight like this i'll
develop the bishop like this
i should really be playing the opening
more quickly
hey thank you uh and maurice 95
subbing with prime wow f5
so she's preventing me from playing f5
it's not a bad strategy
i'm gonna leave all the tension
and just kind of develop normally
the light will fill in i'm attacking the
pawn
expecting that yeah
okay so we're both kind of doing our
thing
playing h1 trying not to waste any time
this knight this knight looks like on
looks like it's on a reasonable square
but it has no moves currently
so i'll play this and she can actually
offer a queen trade here and she's just
completing development though
oh but actually it's funny i thought
like
bishop b7 is just a normal move but
bishop here would be a blunder
because of knight g5
okay d5 is a bit more principled
i could play e5
we might end up trading and d5
nice move
if i move the rook
maybe bishop g1 it's weird but
the point is if she plays g4 i want to
respond with c4
my bishop here would be attacked
and then if she okay oh okay here we go
that's what i was waiting for
the the fork
there there have been misforks in this
match but
the fork has been found
it's still it's still letting me fight
because when i win the rook she'll have
two minors for it and black might still
be
for choice but momentum is definitely on
my side
i think i'll play e5 because i just want
to close the position now
she might end up playing this to unleash
the bishop
um so g2 is a long term target
and i don't have a light sword bishop to
challenge this thing
but i have i have ways of defending
queen h3 maybe queen g3
to pressure the pawn and also to
preserve the idea of h3 king h2
um if she plays this the threat will be
knight takes d3 because my queen will be
overworked
she does so there's not too many ways to
defend actually
uh there's rook f2
which is the only move i see i have to
over defend so my queen can
be able to to capture
wow oh wow she wants to
go into this square hold a move
that's a nasty maneuver
um i mean it should be okay though
because when she plays this i'll play
this
wait i have to count one two three one
two three
i can count to three
man so if takes takes i'm i'm really
kind of annoyingly pinned
but then i can kind of get out of it and
then eventually she might take and then
we trade and
get some end game
um i think that's most likely because
otherwise i
take on e3 if knight g4 i play h3
so i think the knights actually
committed
there's no other squares it went in so
deep
maybe i could have considered knights f3
there to block the diagonal
it's still a maybe idea for later
wow what does this move wow her
expressions scare me because she wants
to take stakes and then
rook takes and then fork and destroy me
but i can i can wait i can takes with
queen
i think it's okay
because my rook always just defends g2
oh but she might take and play knight g6
yeah i mean i have to just
roll with the punches
yeah i have this move
just going back because now
whatever piece takes the other piece is
pinned
and then i just take back but there's oh
there's
hey eric wanted to say thank you i
reached my highest rating and i think
partly to your videos
oh that's nice to hear keep it up
shinobu
2s appreciate the resub
i'm in trouble here if f4 is playing
i mean the game still goes on queen f3
because the queen defends the knight
so if i had one more move i would play
e6
okay we're gonna get some end game
black's gonna be a little bit better
with the
the two miners for a rook
yeah at least i have 94
oh oh this is bad
i have queen g4 maybe
i have to try queen g4 so now the
knight's actually attacked is 26.
um i'm in trouble though
trying to just block the diagonal like
the bishop's the scariest piece
i shall be threatening mate or no the
rook defends so i have this move
it seems very shaky
night moves we trade rooks
okay i don't mind a queen trade
especially if i have this move
i think i'm close to winning now because
there's a skewer
or pin and the knight is such a clutch
piece like
holding holding things together
because otherwise my king would just be
in so much danger
um let's attack the bishop
so i'll lose upon e4 will i'll be up
exchange
or yeah this is even better
okay
the king wants to come here and the
knight wants to come here
like that's the one let's just play this
move the light is pretty much trapped
yeah i'll just trap the knight
oh we might see mate on um on e4
that's not stalemate okay
wow what a match there's some crazy
games
this last one was also tricky like i got
this fork and then
i got in some trouble nice games
okay man this game
[Music]
i felt like i was under a lot of
pressure
like with f3 coming but somehow
everything stayed defended e4 was
was covered enough times hey
oh hey how's it going hey can you nice
match i i can hear you can you hear me
yeah i can hear you okay yeah good games
those were
those were really like heart-wrenching
exciting
uh my stream labs obs just crashed like
halfway through the match
and um but like
nothing's working in streamlabs but the
stream's still alive so
uh that's what matters that's what
matters i'm happy to hear that
do you know what happened um i don't
know i
i don't think it could take so many like
crazy games that we played it just kind
of gave up
yeah the game started the games were
very crazy they got very exciting
yeah i tried to be like more creative in
the opening like some of the earlier
games
it was hard to find like the setup to
choose with whatever piece i was missing
but then i guess in the later games i
was able to like play these weird like
gambits with the early g4
b4 stuff um yeah those two fours were
so annoying i was doing everything like
even one year was like okay i don't care
if i lose this game i'm just gonna go
h5 and stop g4 ah
yeah i think that's the game that you
won like you played really well
second to last game i was wondering
what's the best job
no but that was um yeah that was really
annoying because you played so
aggressively
and so like even if i was a piece up i
felt pressured basically it's still
tricky like
and especially when you're piece up like
there's more tendency to play
safe and um more conservatively
um and i i saw you have like a very
classical style like you just follow
principles
you develop your pieces to very
harmonious squares
so i was really trying hard to like get
you out of your comfort zone
which like in some cases work some cases
it backfired
there was that one game where i mouse
slipped like i i meant to like recapture
something but i messed up this g3 move
i saw that yeah i figured it was a mouse
loop yeah
and then that other game i think that
one game i gave were gods
chat wanted me chat wanted me to like
give work on and play a specific opening
but you you knew not to fall for like
this this trap where you take my knight
you know i was so close i was literally
holding the piece but i didn't drop
it and i was like looking at it like
wait a second this just dropped the
queen
because i i pre-moved the night move uh
like hoping that
uh that you
trying to bring up the game um
yeah that you fall for it i have a i
have a video it's like a it's like
england gambit but it was reversed
um and a lot of people have been like
playing this
uh online and having success with it
yeah i can imagine it's easy to fall for
it to be honest
yeah especially like when the move's
pre-moved you assume it's like a mouse
slip and you don't think twice before uh
before taking the night
oh you're even using psychology with
pre-moving that
that's really clever yeah
yeah the the problem so i have a video
on it but the the video has like
maybe over a million views on youtube
now so
so many people like know the trap so
it's harder to trap people
uh with it these days but there's still
the occasional person who
who will stumble into it that's awesome
oh maybe i'll play it myself at some
point i'll i'll watch your video i'll
learn it and i'll play it at some point
yeah you can play it so it's more common
like what i did i played e3 the first
move
you played d5 and then i played e4
but it's more common if you're black
and when white plays a queen's pawn
opening then you just play e5 on move
one and it's the england gambit
oh yeah and then that sequence it's
actually the like probably the most
natural sequence because you like you
play all the natural developing moves
and
um that's it's pretty easy to get if the
opponent's not familiar with it
yeah yeah that's that's that's really
cool i'll definitely check that out
yeah some of you have the other tips for
me like uh
i mean you know now i have the
opportunity to ask him
so i have to take it yeah um i mean
one i think one of the things is when
you got like these winning positions
um not to bring up like painful memories
but like in some of these end games
where you were up a lot of material
you had the tendency to play like really
really safely
which is not necessarily a bad thing
like you you play like low-risk chess
but there's cases where sometimes you
you need to
to be a bit more ambitious with uh like
making progress rather than kind of
moving around aimlessly
um and it's something i sometimes
struggle with too like when i get a
winning position
uh i'll just try and like not lose my
advantage rather than
keep making progress um and that can
sometimes be difficult to
do of course when there's time pressure
where you have to move really quickly so
i think we had that one game it was our
longest game
um like 130 something moves
yeah that was crazy um where
like you were playing for a win for so
long it was like hard to make progress
um and those sort of games like
sometimes a strategy when there's a two
second increment
you can make a bunch of quick moves gain
time and then
then spend that time to actually try and
formulate a plan
um yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah
that was the move that i blundered the
rick right
uh well yeah you had like the knight
rook and two pawns against my rook in
one pawn
yeah but then like from the opposite end
of that like
when when you have a worse position
it goes to show that you can always try
and put up resistance
and there's there's many cases where
like you you can just keep playing on
and don't have to resign
and i know a lot of the games like even
when you got worse like you were really
like fighting on and i was actually
impressed with that like
when i won material i thought it would
many cases be an easy win
but uh you you fought back really well
even in like some time pressure
situations
thank you so um it's good practice like
having
having these sort of odds like it
teaches you how to try and convert
advantages and
from my side it kind of it makes me work
on the skill of like fighting back from
from not so good positions so um it was
a cool concept and
i enjoyed the games yeah definitely
definitely it was really great practice
and you know we got a lot of games in
yeah yeah i think we started
what about four hours ago yeah there's a
long match yeah with increment like the
games can uh can take a while and it was
really
neck and neck for a good part of the
match
so um i'll probably end up like putting
this whole thing
on my youtube channel uh just have like
a almost
four hour video um do you have a youtube
channel that
uh we can shout out yeah i do i do it's
just anna kremling i've started to
really
try to put out content there
i'm starting to get a lot more active so
oh that's really great yeah
because uh yeah of course like twitch
it's fun to watch live but uh
then then the content will actually live
on youtube for
people to watch so definitely no it's so
important to have a youtube so
i'm probably gonna be putting up this
game or this uh this match as well so if
anybody wants to check that out
that would be awesome okay that was nice
um
yeah again if this goes on youtube which
it almost certainly will
uh thanks people on youtube for watching
as we said links will be in the video
description